dude when you push yourself when you set
your goals right yeah I quit you gotta
remember no hey you can't that's see
that and the problem is you don't have
energy see how your energy is right now
just so low dude you need to get you
need not move I need to look at world
you want a new mood and I got a new mood
I got melatonin spray so you sleep
better
I got alpha brain so you think better
and you focus and your memories better I
got stuff that supports your vitality
yeah I got that big round almond milk
latte MCT I'll squirt it directly in
your mouth that's all I didn't know yeah
dude you're recommending it for your
bunghole too
you never know the bad guys the bottom
line is this is the thing about on it it
is the best supplement right money can
buy
name well that's sticking around these
days what I was sucked when I say on it
these supplement companies who come and
go promise a whole bunch of stuff but
I'll tell you what the one promise on it
two things on it their owners
take their products every day you get me
bf through sponsor is H what is that
this is a train that don't stop and you
need that treat that's right yeah you
body's a machine
it needs the kind of fuel that keeps
auto dot-coms last fight attempts off
the whole damn website coms last fighter
support and vitality and performance
they got it all for you on ted.com size
fighter you know the problem with life
is you don't know how well you're
sleeping you don't know how well you're
recovering do you know my calories you
burned you don't have any calories burn
you not any steps you take well I don't
really know there's no way to track all
this stuff there's no way to track
actually the actual calendar somebody
ads it's out there you don't know what
you're doing yeah people are using their
basic you know maybe your phone connects
your watch they're doing the basic stuff
yeah and then old whoop came along old
whoop came along with a 3.0 strap went
you know what let's measure your heart
rate let's do a hundred times per second
to get the exact calculations that we
need you know what I actually like about
it aesthetically it's like a black strap
that's all yeah it doesn't bother you
it's not getting charged every five days
it's not yes that's crazy it's always
Chinese checks it actually it measures
your REM deep and light sleep so you
really get a sense of how well you're
sleeping most people are not sleeping no
but you're just guessing that's what
that's to me what's fascinating
fascinating about is like if I use a
different let's say I'll use my phone to
track my workout and go oh you burned of
1,100 calories and you did this but when
you use whoop it's like nah homie you
burn this much here was your heart rate
we're talking my heart rate also if you
want to work out tomorrow here's the the
rest you got last night here's your
strain so it's letting you know when you
should really push it I need a strain
thing so the exam this training is crazy
but the rest - the way that dictate if
where you're at percentage-wise it tells
you what yeah man that's fantastic
training level recommendations based on
your body's recovery to take the
guesswork out of how hard you push
yourself for optimal training right yep
and instead the whoops nap plus overlays
our live heart rate calories live strain
in real time with your phone use the
videos you can use videos to analyze
your performance or share with a coach
or on social media - I wish I had this
when I was fighting really god I wish I
had no we're always guessing here
Thursday would make it your hardest day
but now with whoop you can calculate
that man that's right not Thursday
Oh Friday now it says you're good you
know it completely opt exact science man
yeah whoop has provided you guys
$30 off their purchase with the code
fighter just go to whoop calm that's wh
Oh Oh Pete calm use the code fighter at
checkout and save $30 and optimize the
way you train that's fighter for $30 off
whoop comm membership listen man I'm
telling you if you're working out with
your running biking fighting playing
basketball there's nothing better whoop
calm there you go I mean I hope you're
ready for hope you're ready for massive
veins crossover appeal yeah hey dude
yeah we're yet this weekend Gary
Fayetteville Tech is skyrocketing yeah
very funny holy [ __ ] guys I just sold
out hope you know why tickets are gonna
go up yeah I hope you don't know how
they don't mind having droves of white
podcasts with white males rule it's just
yeah my opener is malik and her
both black guys and they were in Tampa
and they were like I'm thought Bryan had
a diverse crowd man's nothing about
white people I hear it's like so one
black guy I was like come on man
are we on chin right we're live Oh Gary
Oh Gary go yes let's let's bring it down
for a second - hold on URIs Gary Gary
give it all no not no not us
yeah I don't know I kind of need you bro
listen listen you're bad guy Brian I'm a
bad guy all the guys at the club I
remember I never talks you to marry me I
hear some waitress passing kind of says
you were difficult at one point God
knows I came in what she said and I come
on the podcasting honored Gary Owen is
difficult and that is so good that
occurred you heard it he's a do you hurt
jaysus and you were like what the [ __ ]
right and I was like I didn't mean it
backpedal don't apologize I've heard
nothing but great things about you and
and I want to say I want to say you
remember who said the bad thing about me
I don't remember her
was it brandy brandy and pittsburgh it
was brandon the singer i want a single
mom mom always got an edge she said you
struck her you struck her and a black
bloc right open her banger banger as
well and then you took a [ __ ] in the
middle of the floor and said [ __ ] you
guys and you left so that would enter
the check so I guess we're difficult so
that's all I heard that's all I heard
that's all I heard other than that I
hear you're a fantastic guy I think if
we didn't tip he ordered like primary
taquitos all weekend that must have been
a sense yeah honestly when I first
started doing stand-up I had no concept
of tipping really I didn't realize she
means hip your greenroom oh so when when
I held all you guys I was like this I
bet you this goes way back on tipping
greenroom waitress days weird it's
[ __ ] how many she was advertising
how many fee how many hundreds and
hundred thousand yeah those that you've
done and then one waitress waitress had
a bad day
and you rat him out of millions of well
here's the thing I threw a little bit of
a tantrum on my set the other day I felt
justified but I guarantee I guarantee
the people that didn't know what was
going on
looked at me and said that guy's a dick
all the room and so we've all had these
moments even though I give a lot and I'm
a comedy Jews you knew you are a bit of
a diva I could be a dick sometimes Nick
I just get mad I just I throw a little
tantrum so you're not at anybody but you
were a dick the last week of March yeah
not that I remember the date come on cuz
I'm sorry the amazing thing is like you
look at your whole career like okay I
think I've done some decent things in my
career and the only time Brian Collins
ever brought me up was yes your
difficult work with I was bored taking
back that we did a movie together and
you had no concept
I'm a bad person
I'm a [ __ ] everything guys ever got to
work with I go you didn't say that right
along you were fine that day you were a
marine though might slay me maybe maybe
still here I was like the guy's a
veteran the whole thing was shitty III
couldn't backtracked more I could to
backpedal more I did film it's unlike
you to go bad I like it's always
actually like really bad it's but
especially publicly I'm on a podcast
just I was just talking one Monday with
that guy yes Gary are like volatile
that's he said Bob yeah he's Reval at
all that's even worse I said I remember
but
that by the way is not what the person
said so I made that up I was like he
must have thought my character ride
along was real
oh my golf my clothes well I like you
guys now we have you here now yeah yeah
I'm all the way from modern Cal man yeah
yeah Louis Vuitton backpack but it's
like and some cats not had some sex he
sweats I mean you're dressed it's free
of everything I have on his free by the
way my prince and the shirt I couldn't
wear that because he would make fun of
me it's fine
well he looks cool in it though it's fly
yep don't say my audience what it's
probably so we're shooting area there
should may a music video sort of
launching a podcast a photo shoot a
music video
okay large black gentleman who played
basketball smash boys smoking weed Matt
Barnes Gary and there are a lot of
african-american people around him
Gary walks and this is on everybody's
like oh okay just even brilliant concept
like I smoking weed so you guys come up
with that these stars are amazing yeah
well first he looked at me so it was me
it was okay he's like he saw you and he
goes later he just smiled and he does
this where he brings his hand up I was
Brian would've done it I know right
racist yeah
Oh big concept over here if not talking
not looking anybody big concept black
guys smoking weed just stay there all
small watching bridge you know guys with
just what she hit job yeah god I would
love that
Oh actually I was with John Salley a
long time ago and I was on a date with
the Chinese actress named Li Ling
Lucy Liu like she's having to learn wait
okay she was in the last emperor looked
that up please I think it's a circus kz+
ever oh the respect now I'm gonna say
something out there just she's just on a
different planet she's just on a
different time so Luke was or will take
this hot
now go to the Martin Scorsese movie yeah
hold on hold on oh you guys don't know
she was kind of famous for a little
while what L said she bit him Brian um
oh my dreams doing a lot of stuff London
keudboon maybe she was incontinent yeah
let me see that good yeah I'll tell you
I got a story for you you're not very
good at your memory movies it's true
it's true I dunno I'm just glad you're
here
I do know you wouldn't come out of your
you're the green room a famous Asian
let's go with that so she was kind of
crazy and then I was with John Salley
and there was a guy who played on the
the [ __ ] Detroit visit it was all pro
athletes and mostly pro football players
and a lot of pro basketball players
mystical gentlemen there was a gentleman
who played on the Lakers for a long time
and he was [ __ ] huge like seven feet
black and he was I'm not kidding he
probably was six up all muscle and he
took a liking to my girl who was dancing
like Michael Jackson and so he was like
he kind of like got over her and started
to bond link by link oh hi yeah we were
just talking about her
she wears shoes on her head watch this
yes this is who I went on a date with
gorgeous but go ahead and take a look at
will do kinda [ __ ] she shows up in
that's her now would you guys meet um
show with her for E and I she's
beautiful and we started talking yeah
that's what she loves and that's what
she would wear nipple is out 4 to 0 yeah
oh she's crazy
oh you have no idea like dancing like a
bad Michael Jackson okay like a bad
Michael Jackson probably no drugs in a
bar and the giant the giant began to
speak to her in kind of chronic and I
kind of like sidled I was like yeah but
you know your place in line couldn't be
more muscular couldn't be bigger
like a different looking human being
would dwarf you you know I was like but
all a probably 300 pounds and I went and
John Salley goes hey listen that guy
that guys don't do that let me figure
this out wonder why well did I go why
cuz he's got some felonies he's the guy
who he'll actually be up right here and
I'm never the Lakers how long ago was
this
probably more than 12 years ago John's
known for that I he'll look out for
people
Sally's a great tell ya I'm selling at
home but yeah pretty great thing he's a
great guy funny he's seven smart 270
pounds and he you would never know he's
in that he doesn't he's not an athlete
isn't like to hang out I even with
athletes he's yeah yeah well yeah he had
the morning show here not wait for a
while for a long time yeah it has a pop
station he got into entertainment
big-time and then he kind of I think he
moved out of LA I so I sold his home
already
in the hills yeah Martin guy great guy
in every way
mm-hm really cool so anyway so long
story short artis volatile he was
volatile he's not I don't know the other
guy was volatile and he goes get out of
here and I was like yeah I were I beat
the China
oh cool I'm I kicked him and that's the
death story and then I I took money home
and I made love with her no I didn't
know I didn't I dropped her off and
nothing happens there's no way you make
love to someone like that that did that
yeah it was nasty yeah it happened
nothing happened I didn't know how to
truebloods though yeah you can go on a
date with somebody who can be gorgeous
and you or whatever they are and you
just
there's given those awkward things were
you just there's no way to connect you
know what if they're hot enough that I
put up with it you put up with it I'll
put up with a lot of shift they're hot
like we write this out yeah i'ma ride
this out you another drink a little idea
sure oh yeah I'm gonna entertain this
yeah mmm terrible people covered bad
people well there are some cyborgs out
here in this you you've been made for
how long 2003 so 16 years a long time
did you know right when you saw old
wifey no we we knew each other for a
year it's kind of funny if she when I
met her she worked for Shaq Shaq had a
clothing line and record label called
twisdom so for the world's Miami flavor
the Lakers often it so I'm I'm open
Mikan just get in LA and Shaq brought
his staff out to a comedy club one night
and she was with them so that's where I
met her
after the show I went to be checked but
then I met her and we talked on a phone
for like a year but I never thought she
would go out with me I had like an s10
pickup a crack in the windshield and
just just a big a little like I believe
a tiny apartment yeah you know so I'm
like that chick she's funny Dayton MBA
and ælis actors there's no surround it
all the time yeah that scene and but I'd
always see her out at different clubs
and social events right Sedona I'll
never forget I booked a movie called
held up with Jamie Foxx it was the first
one we ever got and if we were filming
in Canada I called her the day before I
left because I was getting rid of my
apartment this before everybody had cell
phones this is 98 and I was like I
called her I said hey
I'm leaving for Canada I said I'll call
you when I get up there and give you the
hotel number if you want to call me and
she goes I'm glad you called because if
you wouldn't have I'm moving and my
numbers changing oh well if I wouldn't
have called her that day this book
social media game over who knows
and then I we got to Canada and end up
we talked about every day on the phone
cuz I didn't know anybody up there
I'm kind of a myself he's we're in LA
she's still working for Shaq and so we
end up talking like every day so the
week before I came back I said hey when
I get back you want to go out and she
goes on a date and I went you could say
no she was like okay it would like the
it was okay and then I come back and she
stood me up on the first date she did
and this is when Magic Johnson no the
hell know where I got to hear that so
you stood you up as and she blew she
didn't show up completely didn't show up
okay between oh well here Matt Magic
Johnson used to have this thing called
the Midsummer's Night Magic and if all
the black Halle was there all the a
listers everybody all the NBA all-star
players come in and it was in the
summertime it was the biggest weekend in
LA for black Hollywood basically sounds
fun
so I'm going to all the parties now
looking for like what was I gonna do if
I say I said definitely folks didn't he
hope when I know she's at these parties
and I left a weekend open during met him
never saw her out I waited a couple
weeks and I called her back I finally
called and I said Kenya I said
I left a message I said can you tell me
what happened I said I don't want to
ruin our friendship if it made it
awkward I'm fine I just you know I did
like talking to you though they should
call me back and she said no I just I
don't do a lot of dates I get cold feet
she said so let's go out this weekend
and I'll pay for it I said oh no no you
can get like a Tuesday I'm not giving
another Friday Saturday and then real
estate girl Tuesday might we went to
Islands burgers at the Glendale Galleria
oh and that's where we had our first
date
Wow and then we slept together on the
second date you did not go down second
that may help people don't wait and then
she said she didn't really sleep with a
lot of white guys and she goes it was
like the voice it was your face we just
use like kids smiling at me I was just
so happy
what's wrong wait on this for a year
baby that's a very endearing thing
though and you were funny
did you just date black girls like it my
whole life yeah you've only been attract
but yeah do you grow up around just no
grew up in a trailer park in Ohio would
like like like poor white like
everything you see in the news and like
wow yeah it was it was just it was like
the people across street from me I
remember I went over their trailer I was
like 10 and they had a catfish in their
bathtub and I thought that was a coolest
thing a live catfish and I came home
like catfish in the bathtub that's you
get older like how's anybody cool should
ever cars ain't taking a bath and it was
like eight they had like eight kids and
they would surround Gary come back here
look
that's crazy was your childhood going I
wouldn't call it that now no I would say
with without stepdad oh you know and you
got the bad stepdad he's really bad and
then Bryan Callen calls you of all right
I wonder why
brought the child so but so then where's
the
kind of the attraction of black
attraction the black women black culture
right well I mean two things one we had
this uh when I black kids at my school
what my my sophomore high school was
wrestling which by the way I was the
worst wrestler in the state of Ohio for
three years I was three and thirty I'd
be the same guy three times come get
this what's funny
the only reason I beat him is I didn't
win my sophomore year
oh and whatever yeah no and then my
junior year my mom who never came to
anything she says yeah my mom will come
to your uh will come to your wrestling
match this week acid would I so I said
everybody on the team I go I can't lose
my mom's coming
I can't lose my mom's coming so all week
my coach is anybody's really working
with me cuz I was really bad I go I
can't do all this just give me one move
I just want one move and I'll perfect it
so they taught me the headin arm you
know that one so all week I'm working on
a heading arm heading arm head I'm right
I'm like I got it I got it I go out
there I shake the guy's hand [ __ ]
tried to put me in a hand arm
but he missed it and then I got on him
13 seconds oh what's up Wow school
record 13 second mom sorry mom stands up
and goes in Ohio no the team like leg
lifts me up on their shoulders they're
so happy for my and Rudy and then it's
so funny so that was that's the first
time I beat them and then you know you
get the high school you got the
wrestling tournaments yeah and you got
the Braga's there was eight teams in our
in our conference yeah some reason we
pull names out of a hat I get a buy the
first round so now I'm in the semis
Final Four this guy Evy wins so now I
got him in the semis I go got this [ __ ]
something the finals I go what the [ __ ]
litora the guy was wrestling I'll never
forget his record was like twenty nine
and one and my shoe was like one in 18
I'd beat the [ __ ] out of here yeah but
my only thing was then was don't get
pinned because I was like there's a lot
of people here I don't want to just go
out like that you spend all your time in
a fridge all the whole time my codes
like after this I got it ain't happening
you know my capabilities man I'm talking
to I always had a video I was talking to
my coats the whole match yeah yeah go
this ain't working I can't do that good
did you never you didn't have rustling
any school did you yeah we did I
wrestled in middle school but you didn't
wrestle in high school why I did the
lacrosse oh yeah it's the same season
yeah same season you're all-american
football lacrosse yeah huh yeah where'd
you grow up uh Denver
lacrosse is the same time as wrestling
in Denver yeah I think that's a false
board Ohio at the same time it might be
faulty maybe I'm wrong so is rod no
wrestling was during the winner winner
winner yeah wrestling is wrestling
wrestling you ask it all you couldn't
play basketball wrestling football was
that the fall off almost now okay and
what is wrong soccer right wrestling was
winter wrestling's winter like you
couldn't play basketball wrestle you
can't be sighs well my sophomore year in
high school I never wanted her Russell
no no but how did this Reston get you to
start the red tape towards the black
culture though I'm sorry I'm sorry
so then my sophomore year we had a black
edwin through our school district and he
was the best man wedding he's still my
best friend of this day his name's Paul
Johnson and I really gravitated to him
because like I started asking questions
like he had this Rastafarian
Annika what's that and he was like this
is Russ far as I can I wear it because
you're not allowed to wear that and it's
just like I would ask all these
questions about black culture is about
it right and he was as he thought he was
so he would always laugh at me and stuff
but he took me like under his wing and
there was two guys went to high school
with and Paul was one of them but I
would go over his house and hang out cuz
he had like a mom and a dad and was
a normal household and I had never seen
the house I was just like trysting I was
always like oh and I was just hang out
at his house
cuz it was normal like people would ask
how you're doing it wasn't like stress
chaos from the trailer park you know you
didn't realize how weird it is to go see
a normal family of a normal functional
family it's like oh this is what I want
yeah in life and then so anyways yeah I
don't know that's you just started
hanging out with him and I'm like and
then when I got in the Navy my first
bunk mate in boot camp was a guy named
Koh pero Washington from South Carolina
and he got letters mailed Co para
Co para Washington said I'll never
forget great name and he's my bunk mate
so he was top I was bottom and so you
got to rely on each other to make the
beds and go through inspections and
stuff and he got a letter mail from home
he was on like a John Deere tractor and
I was like I go will you on vacation he
goes nah maybe this probably if I go it
alone farm video in the Midwest but I
live in the cities he goes what he
called this Brotherhood from Jordans
brother from Alabama each other brother
from Mississippi they go get would you
say go blabbin live on farms because I
could do the right thing they all um
grew up in the country what I don't know
you guys bill hey I'm asked all these
questions and I was just intrigued and
then I get stationed and watched it he
says yeah weird see you got bill hey hey
Gary Gary the ever curious kid about
black but when you're in the Navy where
you're dating black chick oh that's it
yeah yeah it's all you attracted to I
always collate the being gay like gay
guys ain't no they're gay I don't know
why yeah this is what they're that's the
thing oh it's a black girls like I
cannot explain it I got friends who only
date agent girls that's it yeah like you
see the hottest wife it's always weird
when it's jut like will you look at a
white girl and think she's sexy yeah
this is gonna put down towards white the
employer you just prefer yeah and then
black girls always like me always like
me there was one black girl a night club
like she would start talking to me it
was the weirdest it was like a it was
like she knew I was here for her yeah
all the white guys in the one in the
corner she's like kinda a little bit
ting man everybody would always say that
they may go how do you do it like every
time we go out you find the one black
girl the nightclub it's a special
technique for sure cuz some black girls
only give the white guy time it hey man
you know me I love black girls it's just
yes mm-hmm
it's very true it's not like I turn a
lot of black girls heads no gang up on
Brian day sorry about that
and then hey and then did you start
doing when when did stand-up come about
when you were in the Navy yeah I I tore
my ACL and the whole goal was to do
stand-up from from like junior high
really you knew you want to do it so I
put it in all my yearbooks everything I
used to tell girls growing up I was like
I'm gonna be famous I'll make it you
should date me for real like you know
what I mean like kidding around my girls
would they like the quarterback I got
underwear eating ham I'm gonna be famous
you know and maybe like and my I'm mi
junior high score I ran away from home
and my buddy Derek Cali and I say he
picked me up and we were going to bus
station and I said I'm going to LA I'll
make it I'll make it I'm funny and we
stopped and I got a professional let me
ask you something dude what's up bro now
you know that when you're selling online
getting your no time can I say offensive
you got so many carries to choose from
right do you know if you're making the
right choice and everyone else is so
slow and it's not easy you know how
affordable easiest most affordable way
to manage and ship your orders do you
know the fastest ship station calm oh my
god I'm freaking out yeah you should
because it gets your orders out to suite
which is French for immediately save
money on shipping costs no matter what
you're selling ship station brings you
all your orders into one simple
interface it's so easy any device ship
station works with all the major
carriers including USPS FedEx UPS even
Amazon all right you know what a ship
station the number one choice of online
sellers you ship more and less time with
the best rates period and right now the
T Phadke listeners can try ship station
fo free for 60 days 60
sixty dude depend on the month but six
you got another code
you gotta get the coast fighter there's
absolutely no risk you and start your
free trial without even a credit card
you don't even have to enter your credit
card open just visit ship station that's
highs click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in fighter
enter your credit card info that ship
station calm enter code by the main ship
happened Brian let me assume you have
student loans your daddy papers hey
don't be that way to the bottom line is
some people dude nice move faster loans
you got student long are Sports stupid
ok dude hey progressive I'm sorry man
Singh refinancing financing again sports
yeah guys you got if you have student
loans you got a refinancing them with
earnest can save you money or Lori or
the monthly payment bottom line yeah but
it takes forever a lot minutes Wow
minutes John little financial relief
goes a long way look student loans
refinancing with earnest can help you
pick a monthly payment fit your budget
so you can breathe easy today get your
finances in order otherwise things get
too unpredictable you got to break your
bank account all kinds of stuff comes up
get rid of your debt sooner restructure
it yeah so your earnest to your free
cashes buy shoes like me all right
earnest is the easiest way to refinance
your student loan saving you time and
man the same way it was when you
graduated yeah if your qualifying
earnest offers customization on loan
terms and no fees you're drunk right now
yeah I'm a little job look he's drunk
with happiness you know I'm drunk with
saving my name exactly you can complete
a few questions online only takes two
minutes you'll get personalized you'll
get a personalized rate estimate all
without affecting your credit because a
lot of times when you check your credit
score it affects you it hurts it already
refinance the loan no problem you can
still be eligible to lower your interest
rate again start saving today they're
great listeners this is big they're
rated nine point four out of ten on
trust by oh wow I love Trustpilot
our list can get $100 cash bonus when
you refinance a student loan at earnest
calm / fighter my mom needs to do this
that's $100
cash bonus when you refinance a student
loan at earnest calm / fighter earnest
calm / matter today terms and conditions
apply
ei R n est calm / fighter was my labor
continuity that what was I talking about
I gotta stand up so you know yeah so my
yeah it's getting dear can I call him I
said a man can give me you know and we
drove the we driving the down list and
saying the bus station and we stopped at
a Kroger grocery store and I got goober
great because it was the peanut butter
and jelly and a loaf of bread and I had
a thermos and I said I'll drink water
and all the bus stops and I'll just eat
peanut butter and jelly - I get to LA
I'll make it now we got to the bus
station and we we forgot we didn't
haven't that much more we had 13 bucks
between the two of us and there was like
you get the Louisville house like [ __ ] I
gotta go back yeah but I I when I joined
the Navy I literally said who's got the
biggest bases in California I didn't
realize you could start staying up in
any city I thought you had to start now
let yeah and so the whole goal was to
get to California and the Navy was a way
that they were gonna get me to
California so that's why I joined the
Navy with the goal of eventually this
damn thing so the first two years I was
in the presidential honor guard when I
was in boot camp in Orlando they said
everyone over six-foot with a 34 inch
waist come down here and I went down to
the Fieldhouse and they did all these
background checks I didn't have a
driver's license at that point I was 17
so they were like I qualified because I
didn't have a police record you can't
have you couldn't have like a speeding
ticket to be an honor guard cuz you're
on the White House lawn alright so I did
that for two years and then as soon as I
did it I was like okay what can what
kind of job can I get after the two
years in the Navy so I went to the
police academy in San Antonio to be a
police officer and then as soon as I got
on the phone with a detailer I said uh
he said where you want to get stationed
I was like anyway anywhere in LA was
closed space to LA he goes San Diego I
said put me there I got to San Diego my
first thing in San Diego I get in the
phone book and I'm like trying to call
comedy clubs and I call this place
called the comic Castle and I said hey
you guys got open mic
and they was like let me check and the
guy gets off the phone and comes back he
goes I can't find him I can't find him
we talking about he goes who's he with
what what comic-book I go what it was a
comic book store
I thought hero named open-mike so he's
like who's he with Marvel DC other what
and I said no I'm answering to be a
comedian he goes oh it's a comic book
store he gives me the number to the
comic store in La Jolla yeah so I call
up there and they say the open mics for
Sunday and back then Bobby Lee was there
open mic and Darren Carter it was crazy
the guys that I see now yeah and then it
was like a hundred guys who I don't know
where they're at
yeah don't fade away so I fell out what
have you before before you go on have
you done open mic before you did no oil
no I was it was cold all right going in
on them jokes in my room are the jokes
carry on
well I'll tell you what happened I get
onstage I'm like if there's 12 of them
micros I'm 11 at this time it's midnight
and there's ten people in the room but
there's 15 comics in the back yeah and
the comics start heckling me not
heckling to interrupt my show but
laughing a [ __ ] that wasn't funny a
little extra hard yeah to blow my timing
they're usually haters so I'm sitting
here with this beer and I'm 20 years old
and I go you had nowhere to go
hey guys go ahead keep heckling cuz I'm
not 21 I've been drinking this comedy
club all night while I call the cops and
shut this [ __ ] down when I said I'm
good [ __ ] the mic went off the lights
went off I got picked up by a bouncer
and winged like it like in the movies
when I'm rolling in front a real
avoiders door I think the you know the
guys like don't ever come back not dust
myself off I go okay I can't come back
here but I could talk [ __ ] alright I'm
on my way hundred percent that's a good
joke yeah that was my first time on
stage Wow and I got banned from La Hoya
cons I cook on Batman and guy NEMA frit
was a guy named Fred he had like the the
crutches if you ask Bobby Lee he'll know
his bob was a regular he liked these
crutches he won America's Got Talent the
hundred thousand dollars
he ran the local comic store at the time
so I started hitting all like the beach
bars and
and there was a couple black guys I was
stationed with they're the ones that
told me about all the the hood spots in
San Diego as in the comedy opened my
comedy yeah anywhere you feel they go
you can go here here here but you know
that's where all the the black comics
would go so I start hitting all the
black spots because I couldn't do the
mainstream rooms and that's what got my
name out there because now when rap
concerts would come to town I'd start
hosting and that's where I met Nick Nick
Cannon was at an open mic and back then
cuz he cuz he got started doing instead
I don't think a lot people know that in
San Diego that's where they can't get
started right dude well he wasn't he was
in a rap group called the bomb squad da
bomb squad was great and it was very
much like a Ryan Seacrest Brian
Dunkleman deal yeah where Nick stopped
doing the rapping with the other guy and
Nick became basically Ryan Seacrest and
I don't know were the other guys that
like go on American Idol and then I
remember so ie so that's how I start
getting my name with there in San Diego
and then I started coming to LA all the
time and my first time in LA is almost a
better story than the comedy store in La
Jolla again I'm on the phone
I'm calling every club anything with a
microphone hey you guys got anything you
guys you steam you guys you stand up
place called the rage it's still there
on Santa Monica Boulevard it's a gay bar
right they go oh yeah we got talent show
every Tuesday cool like well you gotta
sign up before o'clock then you come
back at 9:00 to see if you're on the
show at 10 o'clock show starts cool I
get off work early I Drive up the LA
four o'clock I'm there I sign up come
back at 9:00 I made the list I'm the
ninth of ten people I know why I'm
always second to last in the nine to ten
ten o'clock comes all these dudes are
show up I don't know what's a gay bar
and I've never been to LA in my life and
I'm by myself that's West Hollywood yeah
I'm like this I go lot of dudes here
like 22 at this time Ron it's not dudes
here and then I realize not even getting
hit not kidding he and I go get more
it's not a comedy show though it's a
talent show of course it is
I am straight white male right now I'll
never forget the joke that got me booed
that night I go up there and I told one
joke nothing it was silent it was
silence when they say Gary always good
time it was all singing dancing and so I
said
never forget I said hey he knows when
the baby's born the doctor holds the
baby up by its feet smacks it on its
butt and the baby start crying so you
know the baby's okay with babies mute
and I start like acting like a baby I
was like I think I'm smelling like a
funny joke I'm snacking this fake butt
and I'm getting nothing out of the crowd
so now my facial expressions are getting
more animated nothing this lady this guy
comes out dressed in drag drugged out by
two guys from the Ving Rhames pulp
fiction things with the red balls in the
mouth yeah they drag this guy out his
dong and I get Gong and I was I was only
person got Gong the whole night Jesus so
vision my dumb ass I don't like that
joke ruff go when you bomb you should
leave no I stay like this what do I do
now I've never been LA I'm thinking this
and I still don't realize this is gay
only I think some women are gonna show
up so I'm in the bathroom and a guy goes
hey don't worry it's a tough crowd but
if you need a massage and puts a card in
my freaking pocket I go the voice then I
go out there's I'll never forget there's
a parking ticket on my car go the
longest drive back to me I go like look
but you know it feels like you just knew
how to eat [ __ ] and keep going and
that's a huge part of yeah you know why
in my brain I was like at that point I
had been doing stand-up for like a year
so I was like I know this [ __ ] works
well your father crowd do your funny
yeah yeah you know what I mean I thought
that'd happen then you one didn't like
best black Tommy in San Diego crazy is
that
well they had a radio station called z9t
it was a hip-hop station and I'm driving
in my my truck the same s10 pickup that
I picked my wife him and I hear this
rate of control we're looking for the
funniest black comedians see me a go and
I'm like oh [ __ ] sorry pull over right
the phone number down called up said hey
I want to enter fearless I want to enter
if they go all right so they go you know
that shows it somewhere in Imperial
Beach this little [ __ ] Club show up
of course I'm only a white guy there
there was uh there was a Mexican guy
there and I go up and it was it could
have been the worst comedy show I've
ever seen from the hosts
everybody everybody was bad
bad really bad and then I assume is an
easy win
it was landslide it's like this so I got
anything at this title that I just put
on my bio it's titled oh man gravity to
it like it wasn't that big of a deal and
I did ride away man I think that's dope
know what I mean humility and being
really humble to to eat that much [ __ ]
you know maybe good but for real and
some bad decisions so yeah but I didn't
know just call them like because when I
tell you when I got kicked out of the
comedy store in La Jolla that time I was
like how can I get on stage so what
happened was I was doing comedy clubs
but I was also going on at karaoke bars
instead of singing I would tell jokes
yeah and it was literally there was a El
Torito in Mission Valley on Wednesdays
they had karaoke night so they got to
the point where they knew I was coming
to tell jokes like it got poor people
people start getting quiet you know cuz
it's a bar see yeah they all know this
guy this guy that's yeah so instead of
because they had a mic in a small stage
and everybody knew all this guy's gonna
it reminds me yeah he and I were talking
about how like no matter what happens
you just keep going like just keep going
don't worry no breast guy is talking
about the comp lawyer at the Comedy
Store where you sign up where you like
go where those guys those guys stopped
oh they stopped calling he stopped going
that's it yeah I was happening on the
way with like all this ain't worth it to
me yeah somebody said hey you know
they're like well you've been successful
they were looking at I said yeah okay
but but that's me says I didn't stop I I
mean anybody who did it as long as I
have 25 years you're gonna you're gonna
hit some if I'm standing there and I
just keep swinging even at a major
league baseball for 25 years I'm gonna
hit three a year yeah I mean you know so
in a lot of ways like this whole formula
for success is you just were like okay
cool shitty day it's I tell you it goes
back to remember that uh I fallen I
can't get up commercial yeah yeah
there's like a phone I can't get up i
I'm watching TV I'm like I'm I'm in 11th
grade or 10th grade and never been on
stage before and I hit this comic I'm
like Annie at the improv
tell the same joke verbatim that I had
told my friends at my high school and I
went oh [ __ ] that guy did the same joke
I did
and it hit me like all right my mind I'm
there yes I know what it's like I got
this you know what I used to do the
nerve system I think I stole my [ __ ]
job no no in a different way I was like
okay I think like a standard yeah and I
would start watching stand-ups and I'd
play tricks on my games of myself I'd be
like I'd be trying to half get the
punchline yeah I've watched a black I
know where he's going with it yeah and
at 910 I knew where it was going and if
those comics that got me I'm like okay
guys that kind of smart guy
that's a [ __ ] a comic I'm so afraid
that I couldn't do stand-up like there
was no out for me I was like there's no
way I can do stand-up like I just
thought that didn't belong to me you
know so what I would do is I started
writing jokes and I would tell the jokes
to my friends like I'd heard it from
someone else I've heard this oh really
yeah dude I heard this I heard this
hilarious I do with everybody know I got
hurt this guy and I do the joke and
sometimes it worked I'm more the first
time I did a joke this guy my buddy was
taking my roommate was taking a shower
and I came at her this joking he went by
you just started laughing and I went
[ __ ] man that's actually funny I guess I
mean maybe I'm right you know yeah and
it takes that like you're always afraid
you're gonna get up there he died did
you realize right away that Nick Cannon
was a special talent
no cuz he's a bit of a beast I I think
if you sit down you look at what that
kids done kid he's alone me you look
what he's done it's [ __ ] it's
impressive man really why monster I
remember what I remember about Nick
starting out was how old was he first
flown in seventeen and you were how old
like 22 okay I was little because when
we would come to LA they call us Kobe
and pie Kowski love because Kobe was
just starting with the Lakers and Piatt
Kowski was a whack on the Clippers
Elaine said we walk in right here comes
Kobe in PI Kowski you know what I mean
like a couple guys and Nick had a
manager named Sameer Toma and Sam was
the one that was always driving Nick
around to do the rap shows and then I'll
never forget it I came to LA and I again
I couldn't it was weird I always was
like shunned out of the mainstream rooms
that's why you never see me the Comedy
Store because I went I went and showcase
for mitzi one time I did the whole for
three weeks straight i sat there in them
three-hour lines
finally like you got a spot like you're
gonna showcase for Mitzi great I come in
there's five of a showcase and it was
for girls in me and I was fifth
I wasn't second lastest I'm getting
better the four girls go up and then I
go up and I looked in the back everyone
it was the original room of the comedy
store and I noticed Mitzi had the four
girls around her like holding court like
giving them advice
she never watched myself man so I got
off I called the next day and they were
like you need to make it you're not a
regular I went she had I mean I
literally went
I'll never [ __ ] go to that place it
the rest of my life I've never been on
stage there it probably gave me some
fuel after that though right yeah wow
that was the first time I was I was hot
and not that the universe owes anything
but I was just like just just watch my
said give me a new she didn't watch it I
didn't get it past the first time the
only reason I got past a second that was
because I met I met my buddy sat next to
misty and goes what watch him you have
to watch him oh wow then I then I got I
got off and she goes yeah he goes you
got passed and I was like [ __ ] well that
was so that's why I never did the main
just so hard mean why would you do the
laugh factory or the improv on black
nights I would do Laugh Factory on
Sundays improv on Mondays things like
that chocolate sundaes yeah and then you
know get fat Tuesdays at the comments or
I would do that I would do Fat Tuesday
at the Comedy Store but I would never
dude like the original room or beli
rumor nuttin he won I couldn't I
couldn't get on I wasn't a regular but
now you could you just you I just never
have and never would really go there
yeah I think I've been the comedy store
like three times last ten years
interesting right
but I heard the Energy's changed a lot
this guy's vaali know what I mean Gary
honor but Nick Neil was funny sort about
Nick was I went out to LA I was doing
fat Tuesdays and Magic Johnson had this
show called The Magic Hour
lasted like three months on Fox and
magics in the audience and he pulls me
aside after I got off stage he goes hey
I got this new talk show
they want me to have a co-host I'm gonna
I'm gonna pitch you guys alright so then
I met magic at his offices in Century
City and then come to find out they
wanted a veteran comic which I get and
they think they went with Craig
shoemaker and I was I got a new talk
show host a new comic they were like
this that ain't gonna work
yeah so I didn't get it but whenever
freakin I was back I was I had rent a
room ralph campus of San Diego State and
Nick and Sam come over and I'm literally
editing a VHS tape of like a highlight
reel to show to Fox and magics people
and Nick sat there he goes I think I
would you stand up he never didn't stand
up for I said you should I go it's not
that hard
hey mama he goes alright all said Nick
starts showing up at all the little
herbs I'm sorry so Nick had been a
musician rapper rap rap he's only 17
yeah hey guys I think I'm gonna stand of
us he should ban so all sudden he start
going out there's this place called mr.
OHS had like a Thursday night comedy
night and Nick went up I'll never get
the first thing went up he was doing
other people's jokes and I pulled him
aside if I said Nick you can't you can't
do that that's something else to do he
was yeah I heard it yesterday it was
funny he didn't know your own she goes
okay I think you like Eddie Murphy ice
cream Johnny Murphy started out by doing
Richard Pryor seven call it a tribute to
Richard Pryor oh wow we do it yeah
that's how he do it open he basically do
seems to cover songs Oh interesting
yeah he called it a tribute to and I
think he did a lot on the street gonna
be led today no no no but Nick went up
to did the uh never but he did say it
was a tribute to Richard Pryor so he
would do Pryor jokes and put him sound
like them
he probably put his own twist on it he
probably [ __ ] hilarious different
time though too cuz you got realized
there was life people didn't probably
didn't hurt him there was only two band
all the actors Joe in the main room okay
look back then you could see if you saw
something first of all the comedy in LA
in New York back in when I started was
so different and the jokes didn't work
that the jokes in New York were to New
York and the jokes in LA yeah have you
did New York comedy in LA he wouldn't
get away with it it was just different
because people had different experience
and it's true there's like that the
world was so different back then you
would go to Europe and everybody dress
differently everybody looked at from
there that nobody had lived your
experience now with the internet
everything was everywhere but that was
that's a very recent thing so for the
most part you you it was all localized
oh so you could steal some people would
do that it would [ __ ] steal jokes I
know lots of stories of people but they
now you it's hard to get it we don't
really get away with it now back then
you could get you could lift entire act
yeah yeah because it wasn't it was no
real record of it there might've been
some busty but how could you prove it -
yeah that's what I was it's also boot do
to buy it sets off people I've heard of
I've heard of guys doing that it was you
know this day well my buddy died of
pancreatic cancer he was 42 Sam Brown he
was a [ __ ] monster
Tommy had oh he had probably three hours
of insane material and I literally what
he was would say I actually wrote him
jokingly but he was on his deathbed and
I sent him a text to his wife read to
him I said dude all your material is
gonna go away I want it I'm gonna do
your [ __ ] joke see me I never did but
like like I I thought to myself that is
that was such good material that you I
could have if I had been a different
person I could have bought it from him
and just been open about it and just
done his material I mean it was it was
like literally a crazy three hours like
he was a [ __ ] the headlining comment
oh yeah he would murder rooms murderer
is like he could get up and do I'd watch
him do 45 minutes then just [ __ ]
murder crowd work like nobody he died
yeah he just it sucked he died in three
three months
yeah the doctors like you have two years
my father was like my father's friend my
husband's the biggest partner he's the
day his friends the biggest pancreatic
cancer doc my father goes oh he what he
I told him that symptoms he goes he's
got Satan he gets gay got maybe a month
or two you gotta say bye I don't know no
the doctor said two months two years he
could stop stop stop let me explain
something to you
and that was it Wow yeah but all that
material just gone in the ether coulda
bought it dude I just like to do it I
want to do it as a tribute to him
sometimes yeah like a take a couple of
days old but then be a dope like just
side I don't know YouTube especially no
contribute to this guy I know you know I
know
I mean his family would probably
appreciate that well his two sons that
he never really got to know why because
they were three and the other one was
five Billy knuckle Bolton and he had to
say
vitamist boys that was the worst but
they never knew and I said to him before
I died I go I'm gonna tell your kids how
funny you were cuz they do cuz kids are
so young
oh no they're Michael Bolton like sing
the intro song yeah it should be just
every else's music yeah yeah yeah well
they'll say yeah like we all should know
let me tell you know what's weirdest is
taking somebody not to be modeling
taking somebody out of your phone the
pet I just have to do that Jaya did
three days ago
I'd take somebody out of their phone or
die well I block you all the time i
unblock you it's kind of the same as
deleted yeah blowing somebody dies you
you're like my friend Suzanne Whang just
died of you know your teachers racing
camps you don't have to delete them then
I was like worse I know but I was like
what's digitally the number doesn't
exist anymore and so I went like this
let's get back to me baby blankets yeah
no more cancer don't segue that no more
early death
yeah whatever carry [ __ ] we have some
current events
Colonel Vance with Gary go to vales
that's how I was hey so we talked a
little bit about this in the past but a
judge in Boston just upheld Harvard's
right to use affirmative action yeah so
they're thinking that this case is gonna
go to Supreme Court now yeah I think
it's a good I think it's a good role
rule because part of what colleges have
always and they won this appeal a long
time ago colleges have always said we
need to have discretion so we have to
look at things like athleticism we have
to look at things as a character general
character like we've looked like
somebody who can play the guitar and may
not have great grades but also is an
amazing soccer player you can't just do
it on academics alone and so the judge
said if you were just to do it on
academics alone you may have an
astronomical number of say ethnic
Chinese Korean Lera might be and it
would it would
use the diversity in the school and
diversity is what makes for not only a
very good education because it it
mirrors the real world that you're gonna
go out so in that sense it held so
they're saying they can't just look at
that this is saying they're bringing
this Supreme Court yeah because what
happens is that socially because it was
only like Harvard was just all Asian
like the one kid who's probably gonna
leaving create Facebook assumption here
is the ear is it here was actually what
it was
so because Asian Americans especially I
Deniz gets a and also remember now
you're also getting at the Chinese
people from China yeah Indian people
from India but for the most part your so
now your your chance to be an American
and getting the Harvard something a 4%
if you have an amazing grades it's
really it's very different now because
you're competing globally but mainly the
biggest thing is this because because
Asians especially Chinese were getting
such high grades they're right they had
to kind of like they had to sort of they
would take okay if he's Chinese they
gotta get this great if we're comparing
them to somebody who's not Chinese so in
other words mean to get in you need
forty percent forty fifty points higher
than say this this white guy like have a
100-meter dash but the black guys got
around a hundred ten that's exactly what
it is that's how you're in it well force
women when we get to go right we need to
go they get to go shorter I like your
metaphors Gary you got a dunk on 11 well
you know the fastest the fastest uh the
high school kid is a white kid I know my
breaking all the records yeah he's a
bowling I'm so proud of him man it's
like our Tiger Woods yeah he's got
hundred two hundred for a long jump
I go such a beast well if you look at
the top over that since 1980 the the
finalists in the hundred meter for men
and women
I believe there's actually there was
like one white person as I'm you think
it's so astronomical it was always
Jeremy Warner won the gold on the 400
400 time at the hundred and two hundred
there wasn't there a Chinese guy or was
it hurdles he was like a hundred meter
hurdles yes a Chinese he WA and then
long distance we out white guy
for a while then each Indians went oh my
god Daniels like very cool just by that
right well that's the guy who became a
world champion taxi driver yeah there's
a world champion he was a taxi driver
from Ethiopia or sour Kenya and he was
watching he was watching these people
run and he was like I've been doing that
my whole life try this I could do it
what is that the 1,800 meters something
some crazy [ __ ] and he goes he just gets
down there and he was tall with these
long they sneeze like you you just came
within like three minutes of a world
record then a year later ooh
world champion a year later they do and
then hi John same thing hi job the guy
was the guy who held it was a sweet I
think and this one dude who from
Cameroon or something he was like yeah
but I can [ __ ] jump and he jumped
some crazy height without doing any
technique well that though things like
that like speed and like your cardio and
jumping yeah you can improve but a lot
of that is just natural good genetics
you know I mean you can't see someone
else I hate that when I see like seven
four people you can do whatever you want
live how you shut up you can't support a
teacher that's not really oh yeah I mean
you know I'm not gonna ever be he's just
[ __ ] weird strong and huge low that I
could lift all day and take all the
steroids I'm not gonna play in the NFL
it's just different right
stop all this I'm also nice don't create
a rocket ship to get to Mars like Elon
month oh yeah exactly yeah I agree but
Elon Musk has to deal with his own
demons you know well there's a heat cell
talked about that he can't like you
can't shut off his brain it's like
you're moving awesomely he walks in a
room he's analyzing a million other
things what I'm thinking about it I ever
Fred it's smart like that he said um I
always feel like I'm contorting myself
it gets a little was Austin when I have
a regular conversation that's all you
want said it's exhausting yeah cuz your
contorting your so you're almost like oh
these people are talking about this and
I don't give a [ __ ] about but I have to
figure out a way to fit in so see I be a
guy they would just probably be the
widow just staring at them in the corner
like instead of talking to eat lamb must
like I like why you look normal look
normal man eating we feel that Brandon
yeah I mean uh-huh
oh you like coffee - yeah what else you
got yep so a video went online and it's
of this little girl taking a photo at a
breakfast photo op in
Universal Studios Florida and she's
taking a picture with a minion and the
character grew the parents after a
couple months going back from that
vacation look through their album and
noticed in the photo group had the okay
sign on the girls shoulder and I firstly
thought it was a little weird
Dwight supremacist thing yeah at first
we thought it was kind of weird that's
it yeah but it's like this right yeah
and they thought it was a little weird
and they found footage of a recording of
the daughter going to group to take the
photo and they noticed that at first he
waved her over so she stood right next
to him he put his arm his hand like
right by her shoulder and then slowly he
just kind of went and did the sign and
so they sent this into Universal and the
character end up getting fired for it
Wow
yeah it's definitely do it intentionally
Islam yeah dick whoa and this is a
biracial family so come on drew wow what
a dick so I'm guessing the gun girl take
the guy off me like this that buries me
man no everything's okay we're having
good times when I was called this was
gawking this one reason that below the
waist and be like this talkin uhit's -
yes yeah you get hey yeah dude what a
piece of this racist guy get fine yeah
that's kudos at a fan for noticing that
[ __ ] right I mean how do you nobody can
do this anymore nobody can do the okay
sign anymore they had to talk to the guy
that's super intentional and what I
think raise a mom KKK I think is out it
is yeah I think
okay all right power that's crazy how do
you here's to it
hey did you do that four times what time
job doing everyone's educated on it I
don't know man yeah I don't know what's
going on there interesting you guys any
feel good
why pals go to your phone and erase your
dead friends and yeah yeah died with no
immediate family members you are not
glad you're a Navy vet talk I know who
died with oh I'm sure he really
appreciated that so this army vet passed
away a couple of days ago and when he
went when he ended up passing away his
local mortuary actually told everybody
that they would be doing his funeral for
free because he served in the army and
in fact they found out that he didn't
have any immediate family but he did
have some people that he used to work
with coming to his funeral
always neighbors those young but they
were really heartbroken that they didn't
that he didn't have anyone else besides
people that he knew which were maybe a
handful of people so they told their
local army base and they ended up having
a bunch of people 1,500 people came out
to his funeral
just to show support and have a service
and as there was his family and stuff he
didn't have that they all died he was
they perished guys they perished yeah
here's my question like be honest let me
very come to your funeral no no that's a
good question
that's a good question but hopefully
more than I don't care if anybody comes
to my funeral first of all but I'm dead
right I mean it'd be nice for them to
get together I guess and be together but
I don't I wouldn't but no darked I just
would you go to that random dudes
funeral
absolutely I didn't go to my grandma's
funeral or crap yeah that's it I mean
her the worst that's her I means over
funeral for the living not really for
the death yeah I throw a party I get me
you're all together and there's a bouncy
castle for me well I mean my friend's
mother he was like you know Ida wasn't a
and I'm
melancholy person so I want some
celebrating in here and and they were
singing in church and there was a whole
celebration of their life which i think
is appropriate yeah it's sad but if a
woman's old and the doors celebrate for
sure to us they'll go to scope and like
don't don't do if I died tell jokes oh
don't have no pink ask and put me in a
sweat suit if I doused me I'd rather
have right I'd rather [ __ ] go off
with people laughing yeah making fun of
them what an idiot I was right that's
right for real you don't have an open
casket I told we I always say like you
know though if I could pick one to see
one person reaction if there's heaven
would've been Chris Farley that had to
be classic with all the SNL people going
in on him that I was Hartman when he
died when that all for really wild yeah
Wow and we were just sitting around me
like 97 and me Rogan Hartman I was doing
a TV show and Hartman was close to him
you know they've done that close we had
been talking about Chris Farley before
that and then I was just such a weird
time I'm lose good dog yeah this is
really I think better I started off with
some deep stuff but um last week what
you do you're pushing me to make me
volatile right that's what we're trying
to see here boom you see the Aerosmith
fight yeah
but last week a video of this woman went
viral because she was walking around in
the subway station here in LA and she
was singing and it turns out she's an
amazing opera singer people found this
video and they ended up somebody set up
a GoFundMe for her and they raised
$26,000 for her to find housing as well
as to pay for her violin that got stolen
was her singing have you heard it chin
yeah is he good it's good I mean you
would never expect to see this from a
homeless person in the subway she might
be a little crazy too ya know there's a
story behind her the pigtails didn't
give that away but not a great sign this
is about Giuseppe Verdi
[Music]
maybe it's from Madame Butterfly doesn't
matter though you know Jesus I mean not
sent her any money for the GoFundMe the
weird thing about her GoFundMe is that
it was set up from a guy who saw this
video so me it reminds me of the
homeless guy situation
the guy with magic voice dry with that
the homeless vet that like spent his
last twenty dollars buying gas for fraud
with the deep voice had the talk show
boys this is no but I heard also that
she's supposed to be a in a record
contract from a guy that produced the
David Hasselhoff and England's working
out then singing in concert yeah I want
you guys to tell this antastic it's one
of the greatest things with joy in
journal is you guys remember this big
his big debut and American he had this
big special was the Deo Jay drove the
Bronco and the news coverage just blow
that was supposed to be his crossover
day is on this one about the OJ he's
probably do a true survivor can I see
that wait a minute what he's dancing and
doing Baywatch team there's a lot to
cover here go do this one I don't mind
yes yes I do Alex no when he's drunk
hold on Oh God he'd create entertaining
was good this he has no makeup on
everyone you're wrong
everyone knows it great actor you know
what man so the man god
this is just the worst aged horse the
best could stuff
[Music]
that guy's gonna make it this kid get
his name I don't know I didn't make it
gonna this is he this is so embarrassing
even though I go to one of his concerts
because this get embarrassed [ __ ] hit
he was supposed to have a concert the
night Oh Jay drove the Bronco but you
don't want the videos I remember that
correctly
I don't want your Germany he's not like
your listeners they get all [ __ ] up oh
no they had 4 million bees brother Wow I
mean figure David half the house all ha
man that's probably pretty cool yeah
it's a giant man by the way those family
that had the catfish in the bathtub
love David household he's a handsome son
of a [ __ ] but he's just so on the nose
he's so literal am i that was right yes
he had 20 years ago he had a
pay-per-view special in Atlantic City
that was supposed to have a pay-per-view
welcome yeah you know I remember that
day um for some reason some days in your
life you foreverything yeah I had a ACL
reconstruction that day Oh Jay was
driving the Bronco and you know when
cable like it was down my hospital and
I'm in a navy hospital like 4 channels
and the Knicks were playing the Rockets
game 5 and I was a huge Knicks fan at
the time so I'm going I'm coming out of
anesthesia and they go do you want some
more morphine go undergo what taps and
they let us say four o'clock I go do I
wake up and they say was gonna not give
her cup Martha go oh
next you want a 5 I got stay up mate and
every other doctor gonna keep him up
next you're on at 5:00 and I so I come
up right then you know I'm got the
bedpan in case I throw up and I come out
of anesthesia knees all jacked up and so
but I'm ok so they leave me up in the
recovery room they got the little TV in
front of me and they have to do the
first half also know Jays driving I go
what's up what the [ __ ] how crazy that
they interrupted the enemy finals
that's every channel every channel
before cellphones so I got no way to
know who won have no idea oh my little
bit go and be finals cool check out Oh
Jay light me up guys I want some more
high they did when they wouldn't do that
today there's no one will there be too
many channels back then there wasn't but
there's no way they would stop if is
like [ __ ] that all right how many no
miles but I remember everything about
that day just because hi the Nissan I
remember that [ __ ] too that was all that
was 1991 1994 yeah and then I became DS
and friends without Callens later on
life I was like a cool dude really the
guy drove him yeah he's a play ball I
always respected him cuz he was set
that's a little super loyal yeah
just last about I don't want to bring it
up too much how did you how did you
become friends with him USC that when
Coach Carroll was at USC this of the
Reggie Bush mat liner days yeah they
hired three comics one year to do a
comedy show for the team and so we go to
this guy that started like like who else
it was I can't remember the second year
I brought Kevin Hart though Wow and
Kevin nobody knew who Kevin was right
this was 2004 they brought campus in
2003 I did the first year and I noticed
the comics went up before me we're all
bombing and I go oh they don't want her
jokes this is 18 to 22 year old guys
know girls they don't give a [ __ ] about
your kids home loans so I just got off
stage and start going in on people but
they start coming back right so we're
going back and forth and everything
someone would give me the cold team but
it was like me against like 60 guys
right but it was so much fun it was a
lot of back and forth and so everyone
was like he's gotta come back next year
he's gotta come back and so I come back
the next gen I said I brought Kevin I
said keV don't tunnel jokes they don't
wanna hear jokes just start going in on
I said I'll go up after you on with
whatever debris is left over I'll just
take it and then he goes alright they
want this to me can't get up they try to
tell jokes they were just looking at
them and then somebody I'll never forget
this offensive lineman yelled out why
that sidekick look like a VCR on your
hip kids get this big sidekick and kill
their jokes and then he started going
back forth then it got good I was like
yeah then he was fine there are the 15
minutes and I went up there and finished
up and then I did it every year that
coach Kerr was a USC Tim became like a
thing Wow and I'd always bring a
different comic and I've been telling
them don't tell jokes they don't want
your jokes and I learned that the other
guys listen know everybody could try
tell the jokes I hear I learned that the
first time I did in college I did at
college and it was camera what it was
and it was just a bunch of kids I went
oh these kids have never seen stand-up
they're 18 maybe selling 19 they don't
have any context for this and it was it
didn't go well
call then and then I did University of
Florida and is that the big one it's
like they do it at the in the main
cafeteria dude oh no this is how that's
one Jada Brewer and oh yeah big boy no I
think it was University of Florida
Jacksonville is that no no Florida's in
Gainesville yeah Gainesville and I
[ __ ] that and I just I just started
going in that that's what I had to do I
had to go into the kids I'd start
[ __ ] with yeah I made a lot of money
when I first started I mean colleges
were was that
yeah cuz you know it's just a big
paycheck and it's just a hell gig yeah
the only person I know that really does
college is D'Elia yeah he doesn't mean
it's the older you get old dummy more
out of touch you are - you're like when
I first started like early to mid-20s I
was like dude I loved it cuz I knew I
knew all the songs I knew all the bands
like I'm related to him you know what I
mean now I'm like dude last time I did
cause like four years ago nough like
this I got a good opener and a good
closer for colleges that I don't use
anywhere else and it's a bear the jokes
are embarrassing it is elementary common
but they do have it there they go crazy
yeah and it's it's kind of hacky but the
other forty minutes just fluff yes it's
just trying to get through it man let me
get to this closer yep you know I can
get him in the beginning and everybody's
happy they don't care about the the
middle 3040 no no to him in I'll tell
what's winter about Pete Carroll - is he
created an atmosphere he wanted the kid
being being around like celebrities and
superstars yes like the first call just
so snoop would be there all the time
he'd have like the rock mark wall he'd
have like the biggest names in because
he wanted them to when they practice to
perform so yeah we'd have like big big
ice cube was there all the time
there he was kind of the first college
to head coach to open it up so the kid
cuz the kids if they knew Snoop was
watching
they're not gonna his practice practice
uh-huh but they knew if those
celebrities Gary all those guys are
there before yeah those guys I'm still
friends with those guys to this day like
Reggie Bush really lot of those frosty
Rucker coach Carroll when he's when I go
to Seattle
it's to this day those roasts were
legendary from 2003 to 2007 they were
late err by new cuz it was if the bully
was on Monday I'd come in Saturday which
it was pair for him yeah a coach Carroll
would like give me dibs like this guy
got caught jacking off in the dorm that
really no fun for one guy he's sick
jacking off and then I just walked on
stage and on my way to the stage I feel
like a stick of butter a mess and you'll
need this later and the whole team in
like the guy goes alright guys Gary Owen
just had the mic ok break you're gonna
need that later get on coach Carroll man
oh he gave you dirt on everybody
call unit all right this guy did this
this guy did this this guy this guy's
magazine starting this guy's this you
know what I mean Wow and I just had
opened it up one of the guys are just
back I'll never forget one guy said uh
yeah that's why you look like a small
ass Justin Timberlake and it's not a
put-down I guess like the greatest
company thank you and that's what the
team would
say you look like a athletic Kinsale
so put the team like like I got
destroyed out there yes how who'd you
talk to a house day I stay yeah ball
team yeah did you do any jokes he was
just talking Meyer Meyer yeah
I think urban was doing somewhat of a
coach care because remember they called
me one year to do something for him and
I was like oh he's trying to bring that
in that's always cool though because I
played at see you then see you like a
year ago was a cake come talk to the
team get during uh they're playing us
see I might come in there in LA I see
guys like him I ain't having they're
about to get their ass whooped hit me up
when they play Iowa State maybe a Kansas
State when they're gonna have every when
Colorado was like the team to beat I
don't when they win a national title and
then you talk about 93 yeah yeah when
who is the quarterback real sick
or destroy your Tokyo your time even
before then starts with an A
I don't you got the coat on I want to
pregnant
McCarthy's yeah that's right yeah yeah
they were stopping at the coach's
daughter bring yeah yeah they're like
with Sean's al I think yes a Lusaka yeah
right there's something not necessary
but then these daughter pregnant there's
a super religious yeah but they man
cause ball yeah the Sun it playing
cosmos somewhere yeah that's see you I
think was it I thought I never played
college ball somewhere I forget super
vague a lot I used to be the joy I'm
everything it sucked to play them
there's still not bad man
yeah there make it very they got a
little comeback now they're under
coaching there are three and one or four
and one know their new coach yeah yeah I
sell college sports
did you go to call American University
and tell my rocker tell me bout he
almost wrestled there I went to wrestle
there and it didn't that's my only
regret it's not even ever grabbed them
how did you start UFC fighting I'm a
football player uh out of options I was
really athletic and I was a guy can oh I
can do that
and every time I watch UFC man I love
this sport don't get it twisted you seen
it alive have you gun live never been
alive yeah so intense I just think
just always feel for the guy who gets
knocked out cuz I yeah I merely go to
him yes I feel like this - what what's
he thinking right now
yeah and they especially like when
you're on like this show you was on The
Ultimate Fighter where I was like god it
would suck to get knocked out like the
first week and then you got living in
the house it's a living
hey you have to stay oh you can't yeah
it's like guy would lose the first fight
and you don't you don't get to leave
yesterday that's how I got I got the lie
became a UFC fan of The Ultimate Fighter
because I was up in Canada shooting
little man like 2005 so we had to know
the Wayans brothers a guy yeah Wayans
brothers baby they don't know me either
even they look like I work with you
little maybe he's a baby yeah I work
with you yeah but uh the Canadian
stations they didn't have anything but
they had Ultimate Fighter on for some
reason all the time yeah and that was
the you're Josh Koch mmm Josh Koscheck
was on there yeah and I'm her that's
when I start watching UFC after that and
then uh the year you was on that was the
the Kimbo Slice yeah right yep Kimbo
came to my show like right before he
left the Vegas Gogi but do the show man
give me a know through fighters to shut
up cuz he's always come to my shows in
Miami oh yeah there's a nice guy man
after and they've got it got kind of
shortened to stick the year just luck of
the draw but he goes against Nelson that
was annoying that was on purpose always
was I was thinking that no one else is
behind the women's EXO Kimmo supposed to
fight someone else and the coaches were
like trying to pick because we know we
knew whoever got Kimbo like you were
gonna like everybody's gonna tune in
because it's Kimbo Slice
yeah so we were all going to Rashad I
wanted to fight and we all wanted to
fight him and I remember Dana took
Rashad in the back of the room and then
it came out like oh we're gonna go with
Roy or like that that's [ __ ] up he's
like a favorite yeah all of us right got
[ __ ] up you pick the best grappler the
best chin against kit oh then I was like
oh it's a TV show
yeah they didn't wanted to win they
didn't want to pay anyone know why it
would be you know he's a street brawler
and then you got legit fighters in there
it's just they went they didn't want
that but I mean
where Kimmo is great but no doubt or
what happened just to know you guys
submit it right TKO he he likes you know
later cross them and just el bote
crucifix them really just got wind it
Jimbo's ground you know it just yeah
what's a nicest guy ever man yeah nicest
ever so then you know from that now you
got maas with all which is similar
amazing back street fighting a miami
with Kimbo it then fighting
professionally forever and on the
highest level you know that American Top
Team yeah but his to his point
Mazal all started with Kimmel's in this
backyard fighting yeah and was on but he
was 17 yeah
Oh was he he was 17 and 14 who's like
the Nick Cannon yes yeah and then he
went to it you know they went to camp
and did it right yeah I knew I when he
left I remember I remember when he
fought Wonder Boy and he lost that split
decision Mazda and I was like oh that
guy's pretty good yeah he does he's I
don't know he always he always on malice
he always loses to close split decisions
give me it's gonna see how what kind of
numbers they get taken the yes husband
all that bad [ __ ] I can't wait I
can't wait yeah no they knocked each
other's you know similar those guys in a
lot of ways yeah I would have liked to
see well I mean I my pick is Mazda
honest fight but but to see Mazda I'll
fight someone like but Nick Diaz who's a
bigger version of Nate and probably made
[ __ ] big they won't meet anyone else
been fight or two or X bigger next big
well yeah Nick's Baker yeah
but he's fighting Nate yeah I know my
fault Nate the perfect matches yeah
Nick's way bit why don't you think Nick
is too big for a Mazda normal Nick faces
have any husband alts been eight one
else have a fighter too right yeah yeah
Natan eights a star that's weird be yeah
no that's a great matchup I just never
seems a better matchup
he's these names fought at 55 yeah
that's true
I don't know that's strange I noticed
wat Nathan II be though this is it it's
too ed Nick is just done right he
doesn't he's no more fighting for him ma
ones last time we fought fraud second
right you think McGregor's ever come
back
I don't think so I don't know
but I I don't know why I come back he's
got a yeah I mean you'd have his hands
full what's it gonna do I mean when
you're that is it whiskey too you know
yeah I don't know why you would it's
just crazy to think he hasn't won in
like three years talking about it well
what do you think it's tough for him I
think it's tougher for him yeah that
would be the thing to get him back
he's coming off those losses mm-hmm why
he doesn't want to go out like that
I mean figure he loses to the well
boxing greatest boxer of all time that's
my answer to the one of the greatest UFC
fighters of all time it's like you
didn't lose the Joe Schmo no it's not
yeah you meant you know not like Roy
Jones no my guess who's in the you know
Igor I'm Russian in Russia but give him
starts and then later that week doing
HBO broadcasting like no dude just
stomping on his words like this academic
or Bernard Hopkins yeah Hopkins he
stopped after he got beat up by that
construction worker from Long Island no
you didn't get beat up hold up yeah yeah
and got concussed with his head hitting
on the ground yeah and and really spent
most of his career not even getting hurt
but then he was like you know what I'm
[ __ ] out Roy I get knocked down
begging now to keep going but it's also
like goes back to the Jason I remember
Jason Kidd was on the Dallas Mavericks
and he was 41 the title is how you plans
so well at your age he goes it's not the
games that make you old it's what you do
in between the games yeah someone like
Bernard Hopkins didn't drink didn't
party got up there I ran mastermind you
know he his body didn't have the wear
and tear even with Mayweather maybe
where that goes out he didn't drink
those guys the water
there's also yeah he's a total monk that
way those guys are also fight in such a
defensive way like if you actually look
at like Hopkins or they know they didn't
take a lot of shots to the head
you don't really don't right there just
really defensive fighters in comparison
to a lot of other guys so you know I
mean that's who you think who you think
wins between uh well hopefully all
happened to win Spence and Crawford you
not see that for a while brother there's
just two different divisions so it's
hard to get him together but I'm you
know I was super impressed I was so
impressed with Shawn Porter and if he
had knocked Shawn Porter down mm-hmm
with that letting that last round I
think the fight would have been
so I could have intercourse oh just
nasty man fight of [ __ ] shows you how
good he is but Earl Spence is he just
gets it done I don't know I don't know
what do you think about that um
Crawford be a tough one for him it would
be a tough one yeah because I think
Crawford be slightly favored in that one
yeah I've never seen Crawford he just
doesn't fight the top guys you know yeah
I've never even seen him remotely in
trouble
no I start just duty so crafty changes
nothing strategy all the time every time
I go to Omaha as III go in on I'm pretty
hard and then he doesn't come to shows
but it gets back to me through like DMS
oh dude I said every time he gets tired
everything in a child support like win
this round
he likes over all those kids are sitting
there goes I got this how many kids do
you have six I'd say he's gotta use his
crane Omaha what do you and what what in
the what the one sons us like the best
wrestler in the state Paul really he got
a bite yes dud sensitive dude yeah I
hope he did what he did my show yeah I'd
be nice if he did the him and Spence
Papa and I'd be a great fight that's
what's wrong with boxing man yeah there
is a good thing you have seen matchups
yeah you get there you get the best guys
and they fight each other yeah UFC don't
mess around you're gonna give it at all
you're gonna get it eating a great fight
gonna get great fighters wouldn't you
you've had two fights oh my god no um
with some duties yet but your FC can
lose one and you still good box and you
lose your kind of fight man yeah thanks
they're back well unless you get a
performance like Porter but the thing
about it you can't lose two in a row
can't lose do now row okay yeah boxing's
weird man but seem like you're not gonna
Anthony and Josh for a night in fury and
I can wilder like there's the jump a
heavyweight so fun right now Joshua's
not gonna fight Wilder I mean he's gotta
fight Ruiz first but well they both have
fights come up so you get we don't a lot
of fight or he's no joke November 23rd
nightmare your boxing fan yeah that guy
heard him the first fight I hurt him bad
and I said this and Showtime you know I
just I take that fight doesn't makes it
so
but to do it's the risk isn't worth the
reward I have no idea why they're doing
it look old Fury's doing the only thing
I would say is Ortiz is older he's about
70 and the Mattathias [ __ ] it doesn't
matter since Ortiz lost a Wilder he's
got on a tear just [ __ ] dudes up yeah
the waters like yeah let's run that back
thing all right and you got this
guaranteed fight in February against
fury fury won his match barely right cut
so now you're gonna fight Ortiz also no
one cares no one watches Ortiz yeah so
it's like why this not worth it you
risked it cuz he loses you not getting
fear
Ortiz reminds me of Ikea bûche before he
got locked up yeah
Ike was annihilating people never really
got hurt and then I mean obviously
Wilder heard Ortiz but I thought it was
down Mike I mean yeah he knocked him
down the 10th round before that Wilder
was probably down 7 rat like you was he
going out he got stunned a couple times
oh that's the fighter Ikey bûche that
nobody talks about that was was was
knocking everybody out nobody want to
fight him okay I remember him he got he
got locked up like yeah he wasn't all
together
was he undefeated I think he was
undefeated he was a Nigerian said I have
butisn't man yeah he was undefeated
nobody talks about that dude he was
amazing
beat to uh destroy him be Chris Byrd
yeah [ __ ] dudes up how many knockouts
he have 15 and I bet you all his
decisions were like knocked out five of
your brothers would he get locked up for
Vegas fractional assault imprisonment
Mirage Hotel escort service once enters
room 21 year old said she claimed
attacked her in the walk-in closet
demand to be paid up front but she
barricaded himself in the bathroom Oh
interesting he wasn't all there but I
remember Chris Byrd he destroyed crisper
how long do you locked up for 2003 20
years for keeping him out in 2020
he came out pretty soon held until
September 29th interesting cuz he that
raper does it he phoned a escort service
21 year old went to his room said she
was there to strip she claimed
Ibuki attacked her in the walking closet
after she demanded to be paid up front
okay well attacked they're like that's
pretty loose work you know there's what
goes with the tagged hmm it was really
locked up for 20 years so he probably
was not good I mean he wasn't it wasn't
all there upstairs he was all but that
guy was just I just remember thinking
this is the guy nobody's gonna want to
fight and then I'll say he was not
arrested though it said tough tough gig
was really a lot he's a problem man
so I wouldn't fight l7 tickets doesn't
talk in a [ __ ] no one knows who he is
nightmare yeah
such a stupid fight yeah but the week
we'd be on t talks and the way he he
thinks is like his team thinks they saw
something where they can take advantage
of him and get him out of there under
six but when he talks he's like he's got
a he's got a daughter he needs to take
care of you just wonder is it like a you
tell you time out why he's got the
special needs daughter but yeah Ortiz
had a daughter too
yeah something's going on yeah so I
remember water going you know this is
you know now he can take care of his
kids off this fight he just makes you
wonder was something going on like a
wink-wink do behind closed door let's
get let's get this guy hey take a dive
I'm not saying take a dive that idea
that to me makes no sense that's get
this yeah it's not a bad that's really
not a battle show times not part of it
first first flight of Wilders then I'm
part of we're good okay Bri models not
worth it to pay Wilder all this money
what will he make for that what do we
know I mean they paid him 20 something
million to [ __ ] starch Brazil in the
first round this is healers in Alabama
which is like 80 million in LA yeah
that's 50 hundred thousand yeah yeah
lake house there is a house in the
Atlanta to not the most expensive places
to live they kind of make how many kids
he the same woman for a long time I know
he has one and then he has to his wifey
now yeah they're great men yeah I like
the odd thing he's a fun interviewer
yeah you know sometimes you're like I
don't know if that made any sense
you know me sometimes I say a word
they just like this started at 20 start
boxing in 20 years old Oh later 24 yeah
it was just an athlete he was later
crazy
in Alabama Nike started at Kronk and
Detroit know started in Alabama trainers
for I never trained anybody else it had
a world title look at that [ __ ]
they say anybody what's a heavy atlas
says he hit so hard that he hit you in
the head your ankles fracture well
there's a lot of pill that can attest I
water has eight children Oh what why you
go hey another okay then he's got eight
kids that's why he's fighting Ortiz okay
eight children I didn't know that okay
well holy cow yeah even Marquez is going
that's a lot what is that eight kids all
right plus a nuts bro great
Congrats his pull out game is not you
out of ten percenter boxing it's a
Kherson what seven kids how know it's
there Martino Kumar D for the kids with
like nine different but Phillip Rivers
is Mormon oh is that what it lasts nuts
its same girl oh okay dude come already
has like nine different baby mamas
fourteen kids oh I don't want that
stress yeah yeah dad your kids so you
got a bunch of fatherless kids really as
what's going on that's awesome that's
good for a kid
good job camarda you [ __ ] dummy he's
[ __ ] no we don't know that we don't
ninety four women you're an [ __ ] oh
because you know why you're an [ __ ]
you can't you can't be there for your
kids you're an [ __ ] and it's called
fat it's called fatherless kids he
follows me on Instagram do you [ __ ]
have you - man [ __ ] any of these guys
any these guys who have that many kids
from because you can't bottle I'm gonna
get you pregnant guys I have my kid and
I'll see you kid pricier get the [ __ ]
out of here
no I don't know the visitation rights of
kamati but tell me tell me oh hey go
back to the upper singer yeah
got more current events well one more
this one more oh my god [ __ ] Gary
this is pretty crazy an so guy and Jun
got gored by a bison and then he figured
like months later he would take his girl
cuz what's the chance is gonna happen
again right to spot hold on to get bored
but he was gored and she got [ __ ] up
myself collapsed lung broken rib
what a dick he's even worse it was like
[ __ ] this guy super beautiful so he
wanted to take his girl and his girl
ended up getting gored by a bison as
well yeah guess what I know they're both
fine she died in the legs just also
though they're wild animals so don't get
that closer don't you see that the the
dummy in New York the Bronx Zoo jump
kill herself right she's out of her mind
said she's just like trying to talk to
the lion but then so there's a crevasse
there right you can't just walk over a
fence where there's but there's also a
large boat too right now it has to be a
bit that big of a deal yeah oh so she
didn't go she's a jumper like jump over
that yeah they wouldn't make they
wouldn't make it that crazy I don't know
see that's I saw Sonny be CEO they may
look like she was right I think mines
like [ __ ] you
she's an idiot how stupid okay when they
be Sue's like woman jumps in there
near-death experience and then they show
it over and over stand you got these
idiots like I can do that well that's
that woman I jumped into the [ __ ]
polar bear like one and tried to the
polar bear was like what about in
Cincinnati you know that was that's
that's where I'm from and stuff Harambee
where that can they can parents wasn't
watching him he shot that [ __ ] oh did
nothing wrong Harambee didn't nothing
wrong you gotta kill him you have to
kill the gorilla you have to guess it's
like this is experts were talking like
everyone's like no he's like all the
animal activists he was actually being
very gentle and the next was like no no
no what he was doing he's about to rip
the kids [ __ ] health he showed his
arm is easy yeah that showed it's now
the water and drag them like this yeah
it's just Matt times it guy I'm done
with this plate oh Jesus Christ
they went hey Haram be cool dude cocoon
you got it it's the parents and I was
like here's for ya how do you keep wait
where are you doing it Haram base bucket
like that's a crazy dude to find your
kid I got my kids like this Lions like
any animal you know what I mean well I
always think about that of that video of
the Bengal the Siberian tiger 700 pounds
at 700 pounds and they're in [ __ ]
China and I guess she gets in a fight
with her fiance mom's in back seat she
gets out of the car I love that video
goes around the lion that the Tigers
like I'll take you now mom who's five
foot nothing but that's her daughter she
comes out tries to fight get save her
daughter the line
was it tiger stopped and grabbed her and
killed her then wounded though it's a
terrible story but what war was the set
this was in it was in China I know you
can see it on video
Wow crazy and you see how that that
tiger just goes here you go I'll take
you yeah the Tigers oh wow someone
actually got out very cool several
hundred pounds here you go
I'll take yeah we like to think we're
top of the food chain oh yeah no guns
are the reason what's up but I'm like
this I [ __ ] with a dog a big dog that
comes out to you even a 45 pound pitbull
right enjoy that see what happens now go
150 dollars my Tiger Tiger a 500 pounds
[ __ ] Tigre that would suck I mean
it'll be a hell of a decision I'm not
going on safaris I mean just for it well
the truck breaks down
have you seen in India where there where
the tiger just starts it's an open air
shakin it starts chasing them yeah and
it's like oh yes I know like oh he goes
I the thing is like damn he's gonna take
it I don't get the yeah not for me he's
gonna take it how does that pick not for
me mmm-hmm is that it dude that's it bro
thanks guys I'd you guys don't hate your
little you're such a nice guy you know
thank yourself serious enough to be a
fan but it was funny because when I saw
if you like
you piss I go no I'm not piss I'm acting
like I'm pissed for the stick not be mad
like III kept thinking of managers and
waitresses that in my past that might
have said some to you and honestly the
only one that could come up with was the
manager at the Pittsburgh improv about
five years ago the only time I ever got
in like a heated argument with the
manager and it was completely his fault
yeah it's completely because well I'll
ask him um there this week he's got
fired he this weekend I got fired do my
boy bill Crawford's radio show he's got
a TV a great guy TV I think so you'll
bill he's a really funny comic you so
formal yeah DVDs that's one of the best
morning shows 98 rock best when the best
born she doesn't cut you tell my said I
don't even goes fan they're all about
Steelers guy but the guy at the time and
he so I go to settle at the end of the
week and he's got like all these
deductions I'm like was was that well at
that time I had two rooms on my contract
so I had a two other guys coming with me
so I called ahead of time I say hey can
you see if I can get a third room
instead of two I said if not no big deal
my guys can double up because it was a
friend coming right so it was like well
the hotel sold out but there's a another
hotel down the street I said now it's no
big deal they just double up don't worry
about it they called me the day before
and said oh we got to the third room at
the hotel it opened up great thanks so I
go to settle he had deducted the four
nights of the extra room out of my check
and I went see that's what's it I go I
don't know I said I was fine you guys
called me back and he goes nah man I'll
tell you I go miss understand how about
we split it I'll take care of two nights
you guys take it two nights it was a
misunderstanding fair so he's like nope
nope your contract says two rooms you
asked where you're paying I go I'd like
that I said was I dick this week I said
why you weight acting like this it's not
coming out your pocket you know what I
mean so he was like nope nope nope
that's a fine that's why I have an agent
that would bill they'll handle it then I
tell them hey I'm driving back tonight
cuz I at that time I live in Cincinnati
that's I'm just driving back tonight so
could you make sure that the car is
there to pick up my open or he's going
the airport like 7:00 a.m. he goes nope
nope your contracts is ground Transpo
for you oh I said what's it matter it's
a body get in a car he goes nope nope
nope I was like you know what I never
want to see you again I said and I hope
you get fired one day in the very near
future
well that's air then you're fired no
here's what he got fired eventually but
what I found out his reasoning was was
the manager before him was ripping the
club off so he was trying to save money
at the expense of the comics Comfort
basically no and he was like he was
trying to show him look how much money I
say this so I was like this guy was just
being a not smart lead not very soon
come to find out a couple weeks later
Charlie Murphy came and they said he
tried to pull some [ __ ] on Charlie
Charlie went off like Charlie was
smoking weed in the green room and he
walked in like there's no smoking here
he Charlie goes he opened Charlie Kai's
economy always enjoyed ok you got two
left there let me smoke weed and we'll
go up and I'm gonna form from this
sold-out crowd or don't let me smoke
weed and I'm gonna take my ass home and
then you tell these people why why I'm
not performing tonight and he looked at
me goes now get the [ __ ] out of my green
room Charlie Murphy's know that get the
[ __ ] out of my room
that's a second story Charlie Murphy
like people that I was thought me and
addicted me on the road come to find out
Charlie Murphy checked them like chog
refer to all there's been that guy then
there's a radio host in Birmingham and
he was I knew going on his show he liked
the needle people right that was this
thing to put you down a little bit so he
goes so Gary where were people know you
from and the first thing out of my mouth
was while I was in daddy day care and he
goes he'll I came I saw that and I was
like I mean I hurt million dollar that's
right Tommy so I was looking I'm like
that was an interesting comment right so
I left there and I go I gots kind of a
dick one knee and that's when they told
me that's what he does he need this way
they go but you miss Charlie Murphy was
here he goes
Charlie came on and the guy goes so
Charlie being Eddie Murphy's brother and
Charlie goes I'm gonna stop right here
he goes if my brother's name is mouth
one more time
I'm not tea-caddy throat and just smile
okay no he goes one more time
I love it Charlie just Halden tea well
my time stuff table y-you know I rarely
hate anyone or dislike anyone and I was
to a fault he always teases me for
because I stick up for everybody but the
one guy just if you ever done Mancow
that guy in a Chicago
I think he's such a he just I have
rarely met anybody who's a bigger piece
of sh y what happened
he's a piece of everything he just put
something I would never do a show again
but I did it a long time ago and I was
like get away with horrible human being
he was really he gave you like [ __ ] he's
just doesn't even see you he was on
drugs something at sunglasses he's
pretending to do [ __ ] he's he's a
horrible person
but then I found that everybody else
felt that way too like I've never had a
bad vibe like that I was like he's
pretty nice girl I almost just left in
the middle of the [ __ ] he didn't go in
on me but he was going on everybody else
but he didn't go in on me I felt like I
was my fingers as the black thing I
think he may be nowhere where he stood
like this guy might have some black guys
out in the hallway that's all I'm saying
right I go yep yep right there I go it's
the only guy I'd like to punch in the
face I just want you to know that you
can tell that like I'm never saying that
he goes yeah well he there's nothing
like when you're on live radio and it's
bad radio I'm just like dude you
shouldn't be doing this he couldn't see
me though he didn't know he was so
disconnected but dude there's some time
people are just talking bad there's just
bad at it you know where there's a rise
in some of these markets yes
you know them yeah I mean I didn't was a
bad guy I just think he's probably a bad
person it's like said yeah or just like
100 so damaged and so insecure that easy
it's not it's not possible that's where
it's coming from humans is on him yeah I
got that vibe from you know afterwards I
got that vibe from the people that
worked arrival you could see that
[ __ ] interesting I hate being on
the road and they they have you waiting
and waiting and waiting and you're like
I got up at 6:30 a.m.
dude 69 bro I have an identity and they
get to sit in the hallway I could have
slept so 70 that guy
landed at like 11:00 last night guys
come on I can't do that [ __ ] I mean and
then you're looking at it like this
isn't my audience you're difficult
difficult a classic rock I'm thinking
this ain't sellin tickets no you know it
you know you know it early call me
company whatever when I go to cities and
they tell me what presses I go what is
that so if it's like if Ike I said
classic rock and it's seven but the
hip-hop isn't until tan I'm like not
doing classic rock no picking up at
night I'm sleeping yeah that's like this
we're already adding shows that's right
you know what I mean how what is the
ratio of white to black mine yeah
70/30 70% black 30% everybody I'll press
it it's like I I II I think I'm the only
comic in the history of comedy that my
audience is completely the opposite of
me I would agree it's almost like
Chappelle most of Chappelle's audience
is right there there's never been a
white guy that brought in so tickets the
black people like like I have it's it's
you know you know Sebastian's Italian
Get Rid glace is a Latino joke boys
Filipino they they have their culture
yeah you're right just haven't tapped
into the trailer part yet and I'm
working on once you do that it's a wrap
I got open up for Ron White and Larry
the Cable Guy [ __ ] guys listen around
why recently I love that guy I know
speaking of I heard a story and if you
ever get him on you can ask if it's
valid data there used to be a club in
Dayton Ohio called Jokers
yeah and the girl is the same lady
Rainer for years and she told me a story
of Ron White came there and she had been
bringing him for 15 years and always had
the paper room never sold and then he
hit she goes they sold out a week in
advance all five shows are gone they
were even prepared to add shows and Ron
got on the stage and the head and
changed his act he didn't realize that I
told blue-collar comedy thing just blew
right so he's on stage telling the same
jokes he's been telling for all these
years and the crowds finishing his joke
oh [ __ ] they're going tater salad and
they're yelling [ __ ] out he's going they
the manner said literally he backed up
against the wall goes what the [ __ ]
going on here
why never freaked them out and gets
offstage like what the [ __ ] just
happened and the man's like you hit man
you hit they know who sold out in
advance she was I gave him extra money
because I felt bad cuz his deal was so
he was getting ripped off he goes
because we made so much money at the
door forever before see people ourselves
Brennan like why you probably knows but
but when we were doing stand-up nobody
was making a lot of money like even even
big acts there wasn't like the
Sebastien's and there was some but for
the most part because of social media
you were doing clubs no matter who you
were yeah always you just weren't making
the kind of man you were at the mercy of
like TV oh yeah and film execs made it
we started listen when we when I started
it was you got on sitcom I was a golden
ticket yeah you know now I want to say
Come now and it actually gets in the way
of my Road gigs because people don't it
doesn't transfer I take pay cuts when I
do when I got a film or some I'm losing
money yep I just did a movie like I just
telling him before we got I didn't move
Michael Jai White
it's a Netflix movie coming on June but
I lost money doing the movie but you got
Italy the clubs aren't going anywhere
you can always do two or dates yeah yeah
but you're like whoa I never would have
thought that people think is the other
way around you know we're going great
it's great time to be a stand-up right
now so I mean Luis that podcast you guys
want to never had this 10-15 years ago
hell no it's amazing I mean it's always
Brandon is still being UFC gyms I could
still be in VIP
that was the big worry you know I mean
what are you gonna do now get in the
[ __ ] entertainment all right I was
like I'm nice to worry about him I was
like how is he he's starting so late
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen here yeah
now these podcast is especially that's
this the I fought it for a long time I
thought positive yeah a lot of people do
and now I'm like this dude just once a
week
yeah you know I'm I do it like on my own
there's an engineer in Atlanta that I
send it to but I just record it and
certain people get it just go to iTunes
or YouTube just it's it's called a
hashtag get some and I like it your
specialist hashtag than what I do that's
just a sec do you want to do because I
swing hashtags well there's a there's a
joke that goes with it on my special
where I said if you ever see Instagram
or Twitter and I say hashtag doing what
I do I'm lying I'm completely lying
stand in front of yacht and be like
taking us out for the day and like
hashtag doing people will pick up on
like always lying I got to take a
picture with my opener last week and I
said just got him a new car and I gave
this heartfelt freaking comment about
everything like he's been on a row of me
he's grind he deserves it and at the end
I put acid people sauce specials like
he's lying other people's like that's so
cool man
that's what you a real one got this new
Audi we rented it for the Instagram or
something you didn't do completely all
the time work where are you going where
where can they see you this Friday I'm
in Fayetteville at the at the crown
theater and then Saturday I'm in
Milwaukee at the Miller High Life
theater and then I'm on this tour now me
and it's either me on Mike Epps or then
I'm headlining if I'm not with this at
it my caps my favorite special this year
oh really really time to kitty Mike Mike
Epps special man I just thought I'd say
that let me say it's been a strong year
for stand-up specials damn like it's
like I think brought it
I think Chappelle brought it erver
brought it I'm like everybody's coming
in it
Keep Calm what's that yours win is yours
era what did you say mine
what is your tears when did your there
four months ago oh it's this year Bryan
Callen I'm Amazon right now sir
all right I'm time just almost Showtime
and Netflix you got me back here Netflix
past let me ask you this with Amazon do
you feel like it's translated like you
it the reason more than I thought I just
looked at numbers but so that's good but
no that's without look it without
Netflix you know it's it's still but I
when I find is like Netflix has it's
been a you know it's been a what not you
can't crack for me like I just can't
just forever they won't mean it's very
similar Comedy Central I've never done
Comedy Central either and with Netflix
is the same way and a lot of times I
feel like it's because I'm a white guy
that acts white but I do these huge
urban shows and they can't put their
finger on it they're like
I think a lot live sign if you don't
know why you're gonna stay away from
path yeah a lot of it's just that
there's an algorithm there's a lot of
reasons yeah you'll never know you'll
just keep doing what I'm doing but I
find that if you can get some clips to
get out there on YouTube some good yes
I'm doing
it's especially you can get off your
special yeah that's key cuz I I did a
joke I gave Eclipse right yeah yeah but
I did a joke about black and white
church there any churches and I've never
had a joke resonate especially with my
audience yeah like that one did yeah
it's like people like every time I go
there because a lot of time you do clubs
I'll do Q&A is at the end of it you got
any questions and we'll just BS for a
little bit yeah and then I always gay be
no black church slightly been to a black
church that's funny every time yeah that
clip that joke and it's crazy how that
joke came about because literally I was
at the I was at the comedy act theater
probably 20 years ago and I just was
talking about it and then they had a
live band and the band start playing
Church music and I started talking about
the white light and then it just and I
put it aside for years yeah I said why
don't like why stop telling that joke I
had a while a rehash to come back yeah
came back on YouTube now yeah yeah I put
it on one of my specials and then it's
just been you know that that's what's
great about all the [ __ ] you did you
ain't gone well fellas he had a roll hey
buddy come see Rihanna Brea October 24
25 26 brain proof I'm here and I'm in
Pittsburgh this weekend say Ida manager
Thursday Friday Saturday that's this
Thursday Friday Saturday and then
Phillies October 17 through the $19 and
Salt Lake City get your take his tea
pack a calm Gary you the best man coming
in the final kid we're out